oh the Vijay's favorite black characters
Susie from Rugrats was dope Rhona all
the 90s baby so I was a rug right kid
kraut family was great
Kim Possible I used to stand for Kim
Possible probably gonna mess up a lot so
don't hold me to anything listen that's
that's where we go [ __ ] okay I don't
remember none of these theme songs I
want to undersell and over-deliver but
honestly I feel like I'm like here Lee
that's the fabula is opening I don't
know what the [ __ ] that is
that's fabric yeah I knew I told you
that one Fat Albert
that's fat our right was that little
bill no no I missed that Albert okay
all right clocking at hours yeah from
the Platinum fool ooh Jerry's using all
this yeah
[Music]
listen that was the one person I was
prepared for was the PJs thanks lunch
I don't know I'm gonna hold you off rip
mob I say we're two Parker from a week
that's proud family I think it was cool
like moving out to LA and I realized I'm
like La Cienega Boulevard is just the
[ __ ] Street I don't know that one
sounded like old-timey it was like I
like paper cutout um I got nothing again
this little bill right the home goes
mutters what okay well that's not fair
cause like the part I remember from the
little bill theme song a little bill
well bill
well bill i see remember that one cos
muffin
and brothers used to drill me so bad and
call me little bill what the hell is
that I don't know what that is but I
thought a vibe was that one a curtain
call feels like static something I can't
even think of another name at their
augur this is my boy this is filled
L'Oreal here slender and white people
with the dry chicken and I felt like I
was grown like watching like law and
order when Fillmore can one see Baron
Jamal sounds like Method Man a red man
or somebody rapping static shop just
kiddin play I know I remember it I
remember it now um weird I don't even
know only this one I play guy got it
it was amazing to have these characters
to resonate with and these cartoons to
relate to but I know I think we could
still always do more it was said that
like the only like black animated girls
that I saw on TV came from the proud
family it's important not to get lost
cuz like me like I was really are
watching a lot of shows that weren't
black and produced cartoons and I'm like
lost right now
I think it's important to have you know
yourself represented in cartoon for me
those are the cartoons that stuck out to
me like I you know I'm getting giddy
like hearing hearing these theme songs
that I've heard so long
[Music]